hey everyone my name is brian trong and
today we're going to be talking about
grpc
so grpc is a modern communication
framework that was introduced in 2015
and is governed by the cloud native
computing foundation and today i'm just
going to introduce the concept with a
simple example and hopefully that will
outline some of the benefits that i
could bring to your application
so let's say we have an application and
we have a front end and i'm going to
signify this with a little
computer monitor
and
the majority of the talk today will be
about the back end layer so let's say in
our example we have a back-end micro
services layer
of
python
so let's say python handles something
like analytics it doesn't really matter
but python is one microservice
and let's say
we have another in java
and one in golang for example
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go ahead and draw arrows between them to
signify that these microservices
need to
connect and communicate with each other
i do want to stop here and point out
that i i'm specifically talking about
communication between microservices and
i'm not talking about communication
between the front and the back end
because
communication uses communication via
grpc
does not natively work out of the box
with
web browsers so
in particular grpc is more oriented for
this type of communication
so the first talking point that i want
to mention with grpc is that it brings
about
significant improvements in convenience
and scalability
so i'll just write convenience here
and
if we weren't if we were to not use grpc
it would be important to note that
python has its own http client libraries
java has its own golang has its own and
these are client libraries that are
supported by different groups
and if we were to extend them it would
be different individuals that are
working to maintain these client
libraries and it could get out of hand
especially as we add
more
microservices that could be of different
runtimes in different languages
now grpc
handles all the
implementation to the http protocol for
us so as a developer we don't have to
worry about that level of detail since
grpc implements the connections with ht
2.0 for us so that's something that we
don't have to worry about moving forward
now
on top of that
hand-in-hand with convenience is grpc
offers code generation now you're
probably wondering how does code
generation work how does it know what
code to generate and what not and the
answer lies in protocol buffers
and if you're not familiar with protocol
buffers you can essentially think of
them as
a form of a contract for communication
so traditionally with an api
you don't necessarily have a
api contract that is defined by the
protocol itself so if we're using rest
for example you're just sending json
messages you know with key value pairs
that aren't checked until you get to the
receiving end and that's where it
handles it but with these protocol
buffers
in
the profile which is where you define
the
what is essentially a schema for the
data that is being sent you can define
things like the
fields that you expect
which fields are required which fields
are optional as well as the object types
for these fields
on top of that
in the protofile for the protocol buffer
you also define the procedures that you
expect to expose and these are
essentially defining
which procedures so rpcs standing for
remote procedure calls
you're essentially defining which
procedures are callable remotely from
other microservices
and what happens is if you want to have
the code generated you run the protofile
against a compiler
and what is output is
source code in
your respective language
so for example if this was java and you
defined
in your protofile that you are expecting
messages to have
three fields of
type in string etc
what is output is essentially an
interface that allows you to create
these cloud that creates the classes for
you
that implements the object types that
you outline in your protofile
now the next point i want to talk about
is
performance
and we already touched
a bit about performance
with http 2.0 being
a much more modern protocol than http
1.1 that already delivers a significant
number of improvements
but performance is further
delivered with protocol buffers as
protocol buffers are serialized and sent
as binaries
across the wire
so if you're familiar with json which i
think is the de facto message type that
is sent via rest api these days
you're probably well aware that json
messages are
not
compressed or flat by any means
considering that they are key value
pairs that
certainly are not the most space
efficient
with these protocol buffer buffers these
messages are sent as binaries which are
significantly significantly smaller than
the normal json message
of course that begs the question what
about
using something like gzip to compress
the json message before transmission and
that kind of brings us back to
convenience in that if we were to use
something like gzip or tool to compress
these json messages before being sent
you would need to import gzip or
whatever
compression tool you're using on each of
the microservices and that would be
a bit of a pain over time since you're
basically working on different micro
services and you're implementing that
yourself whereas with grpc this is all
handled for you
so to summarize grpc offers convenience
and then in the form of code generation
protocol buffers
the client library being implemented for
you
and on top of that performance overall
using http 2.0 and
sending very small performant messages
across the wire
so hopefully this provided an example of
grpc in a useful applicable format
of course grpc is not the banded curl
solution for communication but i did
want to emphasize that this can be a
good solution for your application here
are some videos that may be of interest
to you if you have any questions about
this video add them in the comments
below and be sure to like and subscribe
thanks